so then to talk about metaphors and
Python programming focusing on some
advanced Python structures I'm James
Powell we're at PI data Berlin it's
Friday June 30th 2017 I don't know that
we have enough time to get into any
introductions but if you want to follow
me on Twitter I'm don't use this code on
Twitter you want to email me I'm James
that don't use this code calm I've been
doing enough corporate training recently
that I probably should change my email
address because that might be sending
the wrong message I'll actually try and
show you in this tutorial some things
you really should actually do when the
circumstance suits you
what structure wise what I'm going to do
is I'm going to be sitting here in the
front so you don't have to see my goofy
face you can just watch the screen up
there and I'm going to try and lead you
down a very specific path to get an
understanding of four pretty advanced
parts of the Python language as quickly
as we can as I said before this was
originally a three and a half hour
tutorial at PI data Amsterdam and we're
going to try and compress that into
slightly over ninety minutes I have the
three of the four topics that we'll
cover for a really nice story to push
this idea that there are some core
metaphors some ways to really think
about and to fundamentally understand
what these features are about that leads
you to a greater understanding of how
they can be used in Python and give you
a strong enough mental model that you
can start making reasonable predictions
about what happens when you mix and
match them or what you might be able to
do in terms of modeling complex programs
using these features but in order to
really drill home the idea that there
are some metaphors in Python because a
lot of people I said this before but a
lot of people they get really far with
data frames and endi arrays and simple
functions and what they don't
necessarily realize is that when you're
dealing with simple functions there are
some core metaphors there even the idea
of modules and functions something
that's relatively new in terms of
computer science if you go looking
you'll find a talk by I believe was
Leslie Lamport
about how in the early 70s people didn't
really know
modularization meant it was a topic that
people were beginning to think about but
the very clear idea we have in our heads
of what it means for a function to be a
function or what it means for a module
to be a module it's something that had
to be discovered it's something that all
of us benefited from in our education
because we could just take it for
granted just assumed that it meant
exactly what just be able to intuit what
it means but it's something that
somebody actually to sit down and think
about and I want to show you these are
other parts of Python that have that so
I'm going to start with one of the most
controversial one of the most
ridiculously controversial features in
Python I don't know that I'd call it a
feature but it's a interesting way that
Python does things the future I'll start
with is called meta classes and I'm sure
you've all heard of meta classes and I'm
sure all of you have heard somebody say
don't use them they don't make any sense
they're magical they're scary they're
pointless there's always a better way to
do it and that was more or less the
genesis of this talk genesis of this
talk was people looking at that feature
not really fundamentally understanding
what the feature was and then saying
well I don't see how it's useful I'll
tell you meta classes aren't useful for
anything and everything clearly if you
have a fish and you need to debone it
don't use the meta class use a paring
knife I think I'm not sure but use some
sort of knife don't use a medic lass
there is one very common problem that
has many different manifestations where
a meta class is one of two one of only
about two common ways to solve that
problem let's talk about those two
common ways in order to do that I'm
going to give you a very simple
challenge so let me open up a vim and
I'll put a split I'm going to have two
pieces of code here and I want you to
imagine something in your mind when
you're imagine a very common
circumstance in your mind there is some
let's actually do this with a different
one it's like this as library UI and
we'll do a V split with user dot py so
we have two files here library dot py
and user dot py and imagine the very
common
circumstance where there's some library
code that you can't change and some user
code that you can change because you're
the user this happens all the time you
know we were working with open source
projects but it's not guaranteed that if
there's a bug in the library we can just
go change that code without necessarily
upstreaming it because you know this
code may be deployed we have some
mechanism like PIP and our own personal
changes won't be pulled down so in many
cases we have to work around problems in
the library until somebody can put in a
bug request or a pull request and fix it
upstream in other cases maybe there's an
organizational reason where some code is
written by somebody else
they control that code and we can't
change it it turns out it's common
enough that there's some code that we
can change and there's code that we
can't change so for the purpose of the
next for the purpose of this one little
mental exercise I'm going to present you
let's imagine that you're the user the
only code that you can change is on the
right-hand side of the screen user dot
py you cannot change the code on the
left-hand side of the screen let's say
that in library py somebody created a
class and they called that class foo and
in that class they had some method bar
and it doesn't really do anything
interesting okay doesn't do anything
interesting at all let's say in user dot
py you want to make use of the code that
they had cuz this wouldn't be very
interesting exercise unless you made use
of their code so you say from library
import foo and you want to subclass it
you want to create your own class so
we'll call it cooks and we'll subclass
from foo and we'll write our own method
here that's what bad is going to do is
it's just going to return Baz plus self
dot bar okay this is not this is this
this may be so simple that you don't
even see how common it is and you might
have a little bit of difficulty picking
out the pieces that are important the
two pieces that are important are as
follows one we're using somebody else's
code by sub classing from it and two
we're calling a function that we didn't
define that was defined on the left-hand
side here's the challenge
how can I in some Python code make sure
that if I'm running user dot py I get an
error the moment I try to define my
class i'ma call my class something a
little bit easier we'll call it who bet
I will call it derived because it will
make the example a little bit easier and
I hate saying foo and bar all the time
there we go how do we make sure that
base has a bar method that's the only
thing I'm asking you this is actually a
very easy thing to do but let's take
just a minute you have a little bit of
code to your terminal I've only written
seven lines of code on the screen how do
you make sure self dot bar exists
because you don't control library dot P
why because you don't control library
dot py whoever wrote that could
accidentally remove the bar method they
could delete it and your code would
break so how do you and your code make
sure that their code didn't screw up how
do you do it
take a minute and think about that try
writing some code maybe give me about a
minute or two there's many ways to do
this
in fact for both sides of the question
I'm going to ask there are many ways to
do this
not see why it might be important to
determine this constraint obviously you
know I'm the library author you're the
user code author if I change this to bar
I just ruined your day all your code
breaks right so you're going to make
sure that I'm on the straight and narrow
you need to keep me honest and you can't
change my code you can't say you know
can't add lines to library UI you can
only add lines of code on the right hand
side of the screen to use it up UI so
does anybody have an idea what we could
do a lot of choices in the back what
will I do just as simply as possible
what do you think we could do we could
check out our constructor so we could
say def in it self if not has attribute
self VAR raise type error or something
like that we could do it in simpler
right couldn't we just do this if base
doesn't have a bar attribute now you
know this is not perfect because bar
might come into existence through many
different means but if base doesn't have
a bar attribute this code breaks and it
breaks immediately this assert will fail
and you'll never whoops and you'll never
run the drive quote they'll just break
right and it'll break on your end
so at worst you'll get that error
immediately not when you actually call
and use the drive class another simple
way is you write a unit test and in that
unit test you just do and this is
probably how you might do it you might
have some unit test that creates a
derived instance and calls deep-ass and
you say well i just run my unit test
before I deploy the code of production
if my unit test passes it means my class
is correct my class is correct it means
all the hidden constraints that it has
from all of its base classes are correct
and that's what I do
but in either case you're able to ensure
something is correct before it actually
runs in some production environment
either by writing a unit test that
actually calls it or by simply
assert at the top of your code here
there's a very easy thing to do in
Python let's try to understand what's
happening in this example we have two
pieces of code library dot py and user
dot py there is a constraint that needs
to be enforced user dot py needs to make
sure library dot py is written in some
fashion so what you could say is that
the user code is enforcing a constraint
on the library code the user code is
making sure the library code is written
in a particular fashion let's back this
up a little bit let's do the following
so now I change the code a little bit
the library code calls the Baz method it
does not define it itself it assumes
that the only time you'll ever use this
base class is when you create your own
class deriving from it and it assumes
that when you do this you have to
implement bass now you could say that
the authors here might just implement
some dummy one here like Ray's not
implemented error or return something
but let's just assume that for some
reason it doesn't make sense for them to
give a dummy implementation that they
necessarily require that you give your
implementation of bass because the
problem doesn't make sense unless you do
let's say that the roles are switched
you're no longer the user you're now the
library author so you only control the
code that's on the left-hand side of the
screen you don't control the code that's
on the right-hand side of the screen as
the library author you're providing code
to users to use you need to make sure
they don't screw it up you need to make
sure hey if you're going to use my class
you implement this method bass so the
first thing you might do is you might
say hey if you do not implement bass
then I hate you you can put a little
comment right but that doesn't really
help because nobody reads nobody reads
comments they read comments even the
read documentation first before they
read comments and nobody reads
documentation so that's not really going
to help much at all here's the puzzle
that I give to you you can only touch
the code on the left-hand side of the
screen you cannot touch the code on the
right-hand side of the screen how do you
on the left-hand side of the screen make
sure that anybody who uses your class on
the right-hand side of the screen
necessarily implements the method pass
in other words how is a library author
do you enforce a constraint on user code
in other words how do you enforce a
constraint in Python from a base class
to a derived class we saw the other way
around what's trivial it's ten different
ways to do it
I gave you two already how do you do it
the other way around
like this you say in its self if not has
attributes self as do something yeah but
there's no there's no guarantee that
they'll call your net right anybody else
use an abstract class hold on to that
for a second because that is an answer
but it's an answer that's further down
the chain from what the answer I'm
driving at is the answer I'm driving at
actually is how abstract classes are
implemented so does any can anybody go a
little bit closer to to the language
features it's a good answer that's how
you actually do it using part of the
standard library we can you will get a
little closer tool to the language
features they don't see this is a fairly
common problem you need to give code to
other people and make sure they don't
screw it up who here has coworkers
you're like oh boy we better be careful
if we give them this code they're going
to screw it up nobody okay a couple
people in the back are they here who has
co-workers who are here who are that way
you're like please come to PI data you
need to know how to do it the right way
a couple people tell people I told you
in the kind of warm-up that there are
protocols in Python it turns out that
Python has a couple of dominating
characteristics if you look at how it's
designed one of the dominating
characteristics is protocols one of the
other dominating characteristics is that
everything is dynamic there's a very
rich runtime and because there's a very
rich runtime there's ways to hook into
different steps of that runtime what I
mean by there being a very rich runtime
is that if you're a C++ or C or Java
programmer and you see a class statement
what do you think in the back your mind
you think the compiler reads through
this does some stuff off to the side
magically and then I can use it Python
strictly evaluates code from top to
bottom on a script and every statement
in both of these scripts are executable
code the class statement in a Python
script is executable code what does it
do
well in the parsing step the Python
interpreter grabs all the stuff under
the class statement turns that into
bytecode and then creates a certain
bytecode called create class that will
create this class and so what you can
see if I give you a Python terminal here
is if I say class if I have a function
or just put this into a scope that
creates some class
I can create a class in a function and
if I look at the bytecode that's
generated we can see what actually
happens when that code is run from top
to bottom Python does a load build class
or it's not create class its load build
class using all that information which
means there's no reason in Python why I
can't do this other than it makes no
sense whatsoever I can just tell Python
instantiate you know this class object
ten times in a row you never do this
makes no sense it's pointless but you
can do it because that class statement
is actually executable code it's
actually the Python interpreter going
out and doing something and the thing
that it's doing is creating an object
called foo that has a method called call
that creates instances of that object
subject to a lot of the details of how
this thing works internally that should
give you a hint because python has hooks
more or less anywhere in its runtime you
could think well hold on a second
something is happening in executable
code to create derived there's actually
some process inside the interpreter that
goes in and creates that could I hook
into that and it turns out you can there
is a method in Python called
build class and it's part of the
built-ins and build class is just some
function looking at underscores before
and after and you see how it kind of
matches up to the build class opcode
it's just a function that's called
whenever Python builds a class as simple
as that I don't remember all the
arguments that it takes I think it takes
we'll just do this okay and we'll just
see what it passes what it returns well
print that
yep and we'll call the original build
class
now we'll just pass these on so let's
see if this I don't know if any of the
code that I wrote will actually work but
let's check and see if it does Python
user dot py and then let's do this
oh we have to actually have our import
from library import base and build class
might have and I think bill class
doesn't have a underscore here and it's
like that I don't remember all these
details there honestly none of these
details are that important to remember
maybe you have to stick it on the built
instead
okay think it might be like that one
five here this one no no it's yeah it's
here
oh you know what it is actually I did it
I got it right the first time never
second-guess yourself and then this is
important built-ins there's always some
mechanics to this there we go
so let me make this a little bit smaller
you can see the whole code I overrode
this build class you can see it's
printing something out every time every
time I construct a class we have some
hooked and we can do some stuff there
right so obviously we could just do
notice the arguments are the class
you're creating the name of it and the
base so those are the arguments it's the
class the name and the base or the basis
actually so here we could just do assert
or if not has attribute class Baz raise
typer
just like that and we'll see clip
we'll see if that works there and you'll
see that this more or less should work
but anyway you can you get the idea the
idea here is that I think this might be
a oh sorry it gives you it gives you the
it gives you something slightly
different build class give you something
slightly different it doesn't matter
it honestly does not matter how this
feature actually works what really
matters is when you need to use it you
look it up this is not the right answer
in terms of how we do this but it should
get you thinking there's some protocol
and Python so metaphor in Python
everything that you can do that has some
runtime effect probably has some hook
somewhere the hook for building classes
is called build class you get in there
and you do anything magic you want the
real answer for this and what I wanted
to lead you to is the idea of a meta
class I want to show you where meta
classes are important the way of meta
class works is when a class is actually
constructed first build classes called
you don't usually hook into that and
then the thing that actually constructs
derived classes is the meta class itself
and the meta class itself is just
another class that has methods like new
and instead of creating a new instance
this creates a new class name and I know
the arguments for this space isn't body
and then here you can see and this has
to derive from type and you can see here
again it's just printing things out to
the screen once when I create the my
base class
and once when I create my derived class
and here I would just say if Baz not in
body because that's actually dictionary
raise type error and throw my error here
and the idea here is the metaclass
is one of the mechanisms you have for
enforcing constraints from a base class
to a derived class and that's all it is
and almost every time you've seen a meta
class in production it's been exactly
this somebody wrote code on the left
hand side of the screen and they had to
do something to force you on the right
hand side of the screen to not screw it
up what the meta class is is it inserts
itself into the process of building
python classes and allows you to do
whatever you want in this case check
that something was implemented so that
what something is implemented that
something exists in the collections dot
ABC module there is a meta class called
ABC meta all it does is it gives you the
ability to systematically do this to
make sure that certain methods are
abstract they must be defined to
systematically do all of what I showed
you there without having to write all
the code yourself but if you think about
it where a meta classes used meta
classes are used in ORM object models
why because they need to make sure that
the class that you're constructing the
derived class for that Oh RM object
satisfies certain constraints for
example that it's fields have certain
layout to them if you think about it a
lot of problems that you're running to
fit this model very easily one of the
areas where it really dawned on me what
a meta class was is that we had in a
production environment a bunch of tests
running and all of the tests derived
from a single common test based class
and the reason that was the case is that
our single common test based class we
connected to a test database so all our
tests would use test data make sense
right it's in a big in a big bank one of
the problems was we needed to make sure
that that connection was made
every time you ran a test because
accidentally some people were running
their tests and they forgot to derive
from the right place or they actually
know they derive from the right place
but I forgot to call a special method
the set up method in your unit test test
class
they've got called a setup method to
make the database connection and their
tests were failing because they were
either connecting to a default database
didn't have any test data in it they
weren't connect into the database at all
the problem as it occurred to me looks
like this we have a bunch of classes in
production that people have written we
have one base class that maybe one or
two people have control over how do we
make sure all these other pieces pieces
of code satisfy some constraint
determined in that base class there were
two solutions proposed to it solution
one write a meta class just make sure if
you derive from this test class you
satisfy certain constraints you do
certain things in a certain fashion we
know exactly what you're trying to
create we know the class you're trying
to create we know it's layout we know
what's implemented there we can add any
arbitrary lines of Python we want to do
that solution to was write a script that
grabs - everybody's code to look for
problems and then send them an email
I'll let you guess which solution one it
wasn't the metaclass so in the in the
end we actually ended up just grepping
through everybody's code to look for
errors there was a script that ran in
the background and it was just an entire
mess because everybody would get emails
every day saying your code is out of
variants and then they'd send an email
back saying I don't know what you're
talking about and some of would say no
we can need to get your boss involved
you didn't write the code the right way
instead of writing a 20 line metaclass
that just says look you're trying to
create a derived class from this base
class if you don't do this this and this
your code won't even execute it won't
execute without an error and that's all
the metaclass is and that's where it's
applicable now this is not tied into the
full story I want to show you the full
story I want to show you are for a lot
of features of Python that are much
easier than metaclasses much easier to
understand but the core here is to see
that what you have is a very other piece
of Python it looks by all appearances to
be very complicated and come
inscrutable but when you get to the core
of what that metaphor is namely we have
base classes and derived classes
sometimes one needs to make sure the
other ones written in a certain way
sometimes the other one needs to make
sure the first one's written in a
certain way you can see you have
essentially one or two common ways to
make sure that a base class sorry from a
base class that a certain derived class
satisfies certain constraints there's
actually a brand new way to do that in
Python three six I'll let you look it up
on your spare time it's called in its
subclass it's a new method that just
hooks into when you create subclasses
and the reason it was added is that meta
classes have some implementation details
are a little bit complicated but as I
told you at the very beginning the
implementation details simply do not
matter for most of you these are
features that you will need to reach for
when you see a problem that matches this
until you need to reach for this feature
you don't have to really put a lot of
thought to it the only thing you should
remember is where is this feature what's
the pattern for this which what's the
metaphor that this feature implies and
if you know that then when you look at
the details you'll see well actually the
implementation is not perfect there's
some weird corner cases and that will
lead you toward something like a knit
subclass which gives you maybe a cleaner
implementation but until you get to that
point really the only thing that I would
care that anybody remember is the core
metaphor itself because you can see I
don't even remember I do this stuff all
the time I don't even remember the
arguments I don't remember the syntax I
don't remember what the types that are
passed back and forth are I have kind of
have to guess have to play around but I
know fundamentally what does this
feature mean and I know when to reach
for it and I know when it's appropriate
and when it's not appropriate with that
said let's take a look at some easier
features and you'll see that same
pattern of there's a core way to think
about this and if you have that way of
thinking about this feature right then
the rest is just details details you
don't have to worry about until this is
something that you need to reach for and
use and we will by the end of the 90
minutes that we have a lot of figure out
what appearing nice is so we'll be able
to we'll be able to stretch that analogy
a little bit further
let me show you a much easier part of
Python the feature called decorators I'm
sure you all use decorators before and
you've probably seen them before I want
to show you what they mean what they
fundamentally mean and they tie into
another important characteristic of
Python the language oftentimes when
people look at this feature the
watermark for whether a talk about
decorators is an easy talk or a novice
talk or an intermediate talk is whether
they talk about higher-order decorators
and the bar for if your interview if
you're an advanced candidate or a junior
candidate is well you can write a simple
decorator can you write a decorator that
you know three levels deep and what I
want to tell you is all of those are
really just simple details that follow
from first principles if you understand
what a decorator fundamentally is here I
have a file called deck dot py I want to
show you something I told you that in
Python everything is executable code the
Python execution model is incredibly
simple in fact it's so simple that you
might even say that one of the reasons
that Python code is very difficult to
optimize in practice it's because
execution model is so simple and so dumb
just executing lines from top to bottom
of a script and that's it so you saw
with the class with a class there's some
execution right there's a build class
bytecode that build class bytecode
actually does this work of making that
class available for you to use same
thing happens with functions if I have a
function called let's call it add that
adds two things together there's a
bytecode for this and the bytecode for
this is called build build function I
think let's find out in front of the by
coders
so I called make function see I can't
remember any of this off the top I have
two grips I do this stuff I'm in the
Python interpreter all day long looking
at byte codes all day long I can't
remember the stuff up top my head so if
you look at this knee like there's no
way I'll remember that's more than 2
minutes after you finish talking and by
the way I'm already kind of asleep
already don't worry I was told by the
way the first time I ever gave a talk in
Berlin this is a side but the first time
ever gave a talk in Berlin I tried to
include some jokes and somebody came up
to me after the presentation and said
you know the German audience they don't
really care for jokes they just want to
see code so just let me know if I can
stop the joking if the joking is really
getting in your way of appreciating the
pure code I just want to make sure I
have the audience right does anyone here
not like jokes one person do and you
don't like any form of humor whatsoever
just show me the code I'm wasting your
time here okay I have a function called
add right there's some bytecode for
making a function we can't really
intercept that bytecode for making a
function that's not possible
as I said pythons got a lot of hooks in
a lot of places but they're not
everywhere they're usually driven by
specific need if you said we need a hook
to hook into the creation of functions
somebody might ask you well why and it
would be kind of hard to come up with a
really good use case for that for some
reasons we'll see very shortly but that
said where I told you was this thing
here creates some actual exit this is
some actual executable function that
creates an actual object let's see that
in practice what I'll do is I'll run my
script here with a - I flag and the - I
flag will drop me into an interactive
console with the result of the script so
I'll show you what that means
I'll say Z equals 10 if I do this I can
actually interact with the results of
the script after it's run so I can see
all the things that were created this is
similar to if any of you have ever used
Idol this is kind of similar to what
happens in Idol well you can see is this
add bytecode this this add thing is
actually an object it's a very rich
object in fact
a lot of info important information for
this object just like any other object
can be queried directly from this live
so sorry add is just some function you
can even see it sits at this memory
address in case that's at all useful you
know if you look at this this is the
code for these are all the byte code
behind it you know you can see that it
has a default argument hey look that's
the default argument has a little dock
string you can see it there I bet you it
has a name
oh that's the name other thing right if
I say sub equals add you can see it's
just a very sorry if I do sub equals add
you can see the name is something that
is inherent to the object when it was
first created it's part of the protocol
for creating these functions and binding
it to a new variable name doesn't change
anything about that underlying function
so there's a real function here right
now we know from writing simple
functions that when we have a function
we could pass anything as an argument
right so I could write a function called
log and maybe it has one argument called
f I wonder what that's going to be and
it has two arguments X and Y and I just
print out F that name x and y and I just
return f of x and y remember this syntax
all it means is F is some object that
implements some method call go find that
method implement it execute it and pass
it the arguments X and Y so when I run
this code here you can see ad is just
something that has call implemented the
call on it just evaluate the code inside
the body of the function so if I do log
of ad 10 and 20 you can see it it logs
the call so this ad function very simple
all it does is it prints out the name of
the function the arguments that were
passed and then actually executes it for
us
let's seize that is the result very
simple I'm just passing to this function
log another function X now you might say
well if I actually wanted to do this at
some logging mechanism this is a real
pain in the butt because I'd originally
had some code that looks like this 1
plus 2 equals I originally had a bunch
of lines of code that looks like this
and I actually want to add in a little
bit of logging information to this code
so that I can when I run the script it
actually tells me some other information
like what how many times this add
function was called you know maybe this
function is a little bit more
complicated than adding two numbers
maybe it makes a database connection
sort to log it and if I actually wanted
to use this little thing I wrote here to
log this I might even do this
the return value is that I'll even log
the return value if I wanted to actually
use this I would be a real pain in the
butt right I have to go and to change
this user code and this is something
that we rarely want to do here's another
core lesson about Python Python is
somewhat rare in terms of the
programming languages you might use that
has as clear this idea of escalation
pathways or whatever you want to call it
the idea being this in Python you're
encouraged to write the dumbest simplest
code possible that solves a problem in
front of you the reason for this is if
you ever talk to the core developers the
Python core developers and I've talked
to many of them they're all very nice
people and I want you to spend as much
time with your family as possible they
don't want you to be at work until 11
p.m. trying to figure out how can I make
this code robust for a problem that
nobody's even asked me to solve how do I
predict what's going to happen you know
10 months down the line because I know
that I have to rewrite all my code as
something small changed about my
architecture instead the Python
programmer said we want to have a world
where now people are well-adjusted
where kids grow up with their families
and so what we'll do is we'll make I'm
sorry for the joke sorry about that what
we'll do is we'll write a language where
it's okay to do the simplest stupidest
thing possible as long as it solves a
problem and then we'll make it easy to
take that simple stupid code and make it
slightly more complex when the need
arises you see this is a common pattern
throughout Python there's often a very
simple way to do something then a
slightly more complicated way to do that
and what happens is the end user code
doesn't need to get rid of you try to
minimize how much code you have to
rewrite to slot in that more advanced
behavior I can show you some example to
that but I think we'll run out of time
so if you're interested in that I can
show you a lot of examples of those and
they fit together very nicely in some
steppings I can tell you about three or
four different steps where you say this
is a dumbest way to write it then when
you realize you need this you make this
small change then you realize you need
something else you make this small
change and the most complicated version
of that code requires you to rewrite as
little as possible and makes it okay for
you to write the dumbest version to
start with one thing I love about Python
which is the actual code you might see
in production to solve a problem looks
very similar to the stupid code that you
saw in some book or some tutorial online
and that if your problem is a little bit
harder usually there's a slight
extension to that it's implemented I
never saw this in C++ I programs people
SS for many years and the code you'd see
in a book look nothing like the code
anybody actually wrote in production
yeah amen so here the problem is we want
to want to add a little bit of logging
to this add function and it kind of
sucks to have to rewrite this so what we
could say to ourselves is you know what
I know Python is a dynamic language I
know that this def statement something
that can be executed well when I have it
in a module like it's executed from top
to bottom well couldn't I create a
function inside another function I mean
a function just execute code right so I
could just create another mod function
in here so I could call this logged add
right
oops
actually I won't call a log that's kind
of stupid so changes very minimally from
what I had before there we go okay so
here not anything too fancy I just
create a brand new function in here all
this function does is it computes the
return value of the original function I
passed in logs everything to the console
and returns this and I just returned
this log function here and instead of
taking the arguments up here this just
takes the original function okay and I
do this what did I do
I wrote my function normally then I said
take that function pass it into this log
function which dynamically creates a
brand new function that calls the
original thing I passed in logs
everything - so irritating logs
everything to the screen returns the
original value remember that if I rewind
a little bit
my original log function just had those
same lines in slightly different order
this is what the original log function
looks like my new function just passes
this in that's what it looks like now
slightly different and then down here I
just say add equals log add and you can
see I have my little log and behavior
here and here another common thing you
might see about Python is Python
programmers want to make your life easy
and so when they start to see very
common patterns arise they're usually
pretty amenable to giving you simple
syntax to make this easy so a decorator
all a decorator is is whenever you see
the pattern of x equals some function
called on X where this X here is either
a class or a def statement you just
replace it with yes this here is merely
syntax for writing this at the end
that's it there's nothing more to
decorators people like to talk about
decorators as being a function that
takes a function returns a function
really all a decorator is
is an app that proceeds a death that
just means this ad equals log n that's
all there is now as a metaphor the
decorator itself does not introduce any
new metaphors to Python it does it's
merely convenient syntax to access
existing metaphors where that existing
metaphor is the idea that everything is
an object including functions everything
is executed in this linear fashion
therefore you can create a function
within a function return it reassign the
name and go along with your day such
that this end user code does not have to
change that's all there is to that
feature it's very simple let's look at a
slightly harder feature generators now a
lot of you have used generators but I
find that a lot of people don't quite
realize exactly what a generator is all
about I told you at the very beginning
in the warm-up that there is a close
correspondence between syntax like this
and some underscore method so I'm
curious if you could tell me what's the
difference between this
what syndromes going to add one and add
two if you're the user and you're not
going to poke around the internals so
obviously you poke around the internals
you can see and don't say well they're
written differently obviously if you
look at the source code they're written
differently but from the perspective of
the user I told you that when you do
something here with parentheses after it
it just calls this special method here
while you think about that let me get
this on the screen for you and let me
just pull this up in a Python terminal
add one 10 and 20 what's 10 plus 20
nobody it's 30 add to 100 plus 200
what's 100 plus 200 type error now it's
300 it's 300 well I can't tell the
difference in the two of these but from
from an end-user perspective what's the
difference I mean they're both things
that have parentheses after them the add
in fact if you first wrote this and then
you swapped it out with this I'd never
know the difference
remember how I told you there's a really
easy way to write things in Python that
doesn't solve every problem and then a
slightly harder way to write it that
solves a couple more problems this might
be an example of just that in fact let
me make this a little bit fancier I'll
show you one way where you can
immediately see a difference
are these different yeah
every time I call add to this secret
little number behind the scenes gets
stuck in to the results let's rerun that
again hope this should be self dot I
mmm that guy gets got in there something
interesting is happening here it's
actually a way you can do it and add one
using a closure we won't talk about that
we do not have enough time to talk about
closure objects equivalents but the idea
being here that maybe if you needed to
have some local state for this function
this might be an easy way to write it
you need to have some little counter
that kind of takes a function that looks
like it doesn't take any arguments and
slip in an extra argument in there that
you can manipulate let me start over
I told you that everything in Python I
didn't say everything that's too much
but I told you a lot of things in Python
there's some syntax and there's some
corresponding underscore methods well if
I say this if I have some code looks
like this X for our for X and XS do
something with X what actually happens
behind the scenes I'll tell you behind
the scenes internally if you look at the
bytecode Python does the following
so not literally but in a say figurative
way Python takes simple code for X and
XS and turns it into some structure
looks like this I say not literally
because it doesn't actually literally go
in there and perform this translation
but what I'm trying to express is that
if you look at what actually happens
when you call this this is what happens
behind the scenes code that looks like
this well look there's a top-level
function here and a top-level function
here okay there's two top-level
functions you think you can override
what they do of course you can what are
the names of the functions that you
implement to override them well just the
word inner with underscores before and
the word next with underscores before so
let's think about that that means and I
don't know I don't know I don't know
that all the arguments that capacity
well actually these don't take any
arguments I don't know all the arguments
could pass all the functions actually
we'll call this simple
and we'll initialize this okay I know I
can I can fit this into my iteration
syntax because I know behind the scenes
in order to be able to iterate over
something I just have to be able to call
it or next all right this is going
somewhere don't worry this is going
somewhere so I could say for X in foo
print X and you'll see it starts putting
numbers to the screen it just calls it
err it's something to do anything
interesting at all and it calls next
which justices let's think about this
for a second it's kind of interesting
right because notice what could go under
this next function could be anything
here we kind of think about this for
loop as oh you're iterating over the
elements in something but anything could
go under this next Clause right anything
that I could put into a normal function
unbounded amount of stuff what if I had
some really slow computation that I put
here and we'll just represent instead of
writing out a sloka slow computational
just represented by asleep it's my
representation for a slow computation
you notice every time you iterate over
this foo object it's able to perform any
arbitrary computation including a slow
one but it only performs the computation
when you ask for the next element for
example let's save this if I say for
index X in enumerate foo if index
greater than five break out of the loop
otherwise print X what will it do it'll
go through my little object it'll try
and grab the first five elements as part
of grabbing each subsequent element it
will perform my slow computation ie my
sleep and you can see that's one lot
slow computation two three four five but
if you think about it you needed to need
to get six in us remember the enumerate
starts counting from zero so that's why
we had six things showing here but if
you think about it this could be any
very long computation that can
maintain some state because it's
attached to some object so like in the
previous example where I added in self
is some state I would get incremented
and mutate that cut or affect the
computation every time I could have that
under this next and I'm only paying for
the computation as I do the iterations
let's start over
see if we can kind of mix these things
together so what I said was I can have
some class and that class can have some
internal state something that it keeps
track of right I can put a call method
on it and I can make use of that state
right here I'm making use of that today
instead of putting a call method on it I
could put an interim method on it and a
next method and do exactly what I was
going to do in that call method except I
can't take arguments but I could still
make use of that state the only
difference between this next method in a
call method is the call method I could
pass arguments the next method I can't
pass arguments there's no there's no way
in the syntax to put that in there not
quite we won't get into how you actually
do that but not quite and this is more
or less equivalent to my kind of
function written using call that's all a
generator is when I write some generator
like this
this is just some really simple syntax
to write something that looks like this
and let me and in fact if you really
squint can't you see all the common
pieces I started this off by saying if
you want to write a function
you could write it in both fashions you
see how there's a correspondence between
these these are both essentially simple
syntax to implement this generator
formulation and this function
formulation just very simple syntax to
fit into the Python protocols that's all
a generator really is people talk about
generators they're merely some syntax to
fit into this structure however unlike
the decorator where the decorator was
purely syntax the generator brings with
it certain metaphorical implications and
the metaphorical implications are as
follows let's think about this for a
second this call function may perform a
slow computation right but every time I
call this call function it only has the
ability to sorry this call function may
perform some slow computation say it's
returning multiple values at every time
I call this call function I'm
essentially restarting that computation
notice here I restart the computation
from the top every time in this
generator notice I don't restart the
computation every time I yield I yield
control back to the user the computation
doesn't get restarted the general has a
couple of implications one of them is
ignoring that behind the scenes it's
just some object protocols that are set
up behind the scenes if this generator
wanted to return multiple values like a
list of values and this function want to
turn for a list of values and they both
did this by making use of some very slow
computational function the functional
formulation would be eager and the
generator function would be lazy let me
show you this with a common example with
generators one of the most common
examples that people use for generators
is a generator that gives you values off
of the Fibonacci sequence and the reason
they do that is because its
implementation is fairly easy to read
looks like this and when you look at
this in correspondence to the functional
implementation you begin to see some of
the metaphorical implementation
metaphorical in
locations here and then we'd use this
same right here let's take let's squint
to take a look at the two the
differences here
well notice the Fibonacci in the in the
functional formulation had to allocate
storage for the return value is going
generator didn't return didn't allocate
any storage why because the syntax for
the two is slightly different next let's
look at this notice that the Fibonacci
sequence had to tell you how many values
you are pulling out here it's pulling
out ten values whereas the generator
formulation just runs forever why think
about this syntax the syntax for calling
says go off do this formula do this
computation give me the result it's
eager when we call this we have some
result equals fib like that and it goes
off it calls this function it does takes
all the cost of going through this loop
ten times maybe I'll simulate some hard
function it pays for all that cost
upfront and gives you the result in the
generator formulation if I mock up some
long-running or complex computation in
there notice we don't pay the cost
upfront because by virtue of the syntax
each time we ask for another item out of
this stream we then pay that cost and so
if we do not ask for many items out of
the stream if we for example only ask
for the first five we only pay the cost
for the first five computations you'll
see with these two very simple
formulations of essentially the same
thing that first metaphorical
implementation generators are lazy
constructs generators do not provide or
do not perform computations until you
ask them to where as functions
necessarily have one entrance and one
exit and between that entrance up here
and the exit wherever that return is
they
have to pay the cost of every
computation they do because they have no
chance to defer that computation
anywhere else whereas the generator does
not have to pay that cost you have one
entrance point and then you yield a
value but you don't close the generator
you don't stop you don't destroy the
state that's there you keep that state
around and if you want the next value
you just resume from where you left off
it's one of the fundamental metaphorical
implementations implications of a
generator there's more to a generator
that is very important and this is
something that most people do not see
about generators generators are not
fundamentally just about laziness versus
eagerness there's one other piece you've
all seen code that looks like this
right and I'll actually make this a
little bit so you'll see this you've all
seen some class where somewhere in the
documentation somebody said here's three
methods on this class call them in this
order or else if you call this last one
here first things blow up maybe this one
sets up a database connection this one
closes the database connection and this
one here does something with a database
so if you try and close the connection
before you open it all hell breaks loose
in user code somebody probably then did
this because even though the names are
very clear this class is fundamentally
lying to the structure of the class says
you could call these in any order
the names tell you something different
but I'm sure we've all had a situation
where you know what was said was not
what was meant where the generators come
into this think about this here we have
a computation that's split into three
parts that can be run in any order
whatsoever
here we have a generator that has three
computations and remember a generator
only ever performs the computation when
you ask it to so the way you'd use this
if you'd say something like this that's
the first computation the second
computation the last computation right
can you call these in the wrong order in
the generator no so fundamental things
about generator is that they enforce
sequencing generators are not just
laziness versus eagerness but they are
about the enforcement of sequencing
because they allow you to break up a
single computation into specific parts
normally that computation is done in
sequence because that computation is
building some structure like the
elements from or performing some
operation in a natural order like what's
the next element out of this Fibonacci
sequence but there's no reason why the
generator campus is performing arbitrary
functions in unenforced sequencing that
brings us to the last topic I want to
talk about hopefully we'll get through
this context managers there is a very
simple metaphor for context managers for
generators I know a lot of you may have
missed why that last metaphor was
important in this example you'll see all
of this come together and you'll see why
these metaphors understanding these
metaphors even if you never remember the
syntax until you need it it's so
important many of you have seen the
context manager structure like this
let's do this let's make this cg x wy
yeah go ahead now it's a little bit late
how about this that better yes no you
want another joke I'll tell you no the
joke because that helps you here we go
we've all seen context managers before
you have them you have something looks
like this with open some file name let's
even open ourselves to x2i as f for line
and f print out the lines right and the
reason that we were told context
managers are important
it's because in a simple structure like
this we ensure that if you leave this
block the file gets closed many of us
have seen the context manager in the
context of things like database
connections so you can say with connect
test DB as connection cursor equals
connection cursor corrode execute and
then some SQL here you've seen people
write this the reason people write this
is they want to say if you open the
database you want to close the database
the metaphor should jump out at you
context managers are all about how do we
perform some action such that there's
some corresponding setup and teardown
and if we do the setup we're sure to do
the teardown and search through all of
the problems that you've worked on where
if you set it up you gotta tear it down
if you start it you gotta clean up a lot
of different things look like that right
I want to show you an example using this
SQLite example that brings together all
of the metaphors one of the things that
we might do an SQLite database like this
is create a temporary table what do you
think we probably want to do after we're
done using that temporary table when I
drop it well look there's a
corresponding setup and teardown
the setup is create the temporary table
the teardown is destroy the temporary
table we want to make sure the teardown
always occurs if the set up occurred and
we want to make sure there's no way for
us to easily avoid that happening what
we also know is that in Python for every
piece of syntax like with X as with CTX
as X there's probably some corresponding
underscore methods I'll tell you what
happens here this more or less turns
into the following enter try whatever
was there finally exit exit there's no
top level function for these you can see
quite quite clearly what you need to
implement in order to build your own
context manager some function called
enter and some function called exit I
warn you I never remember what the
arguments for enter and exit are I
always have to look the documentation I
know a lot about context managers but
knowing the argument themselves just
simply doesn't matter doesn't matter
that much what knowing what it's for
matters far more and what it's for is I
do some setup and I want to do some
teardown and I need to keep those
closely linked and I need to make sure I
don't accidentally forget the teardown
let me show you how to implement a
context manager that would create a
temporary table in a database so maybe
we create a temporary table with this
cursor and we'll just hard code what
that temporary table looks like and
we'll say four row incur dot select
select star from temp will just print
out will just print out the results of
this okay well I know need to have some
class in a class will be called temp
table I know it needs to take some
cursor because I'll need to use that
cursor to actually execute stuff against
the database so I'll just save that I
know it needs to implement enter and it
needs to implement exit I do not ever
remember what the arguments were exit is
and you'll see why I don't but I don't
turns out I don't have to because are
not that important what do i do on
answer on enter I might just do Kurd
execute kurta execute create table temp
and the definition maybe we have X as an
int and why isn't it that's right I
think and then exit we might just do
card execute drop table temp okay pretty
simple let's see if this actually worked
I'm not I'm not convinced I got that one
right
oh yes thank you someone's paying
attention because I stop telling jokes
that's why and you can see our color
changing because never works out
perfectly oh this should be Kurata
execute yep there we go and we need to
insert let's do a little bit of insert
so we did this will say curd I've
execute insert into temp X Y values 1 1
so we'll do this get it add data and
we'll say for X Y in zip range 10 range
10 to 20 there we go so we'll insert a
couple of values and we'll just select
them out okay there we go you saw the
values got entered selected and you see
every time I run this if there's a
little error in this statement here by
virtue of using the context manager when
I run this again uptempo already exists
so we've got to do the exit didn't get
called let's do the exit kind of failed
to get called correctly but ideally the
exit gets called and I think it's
cleaned up after itself that's the idea
sometimes it works sometimes it doesn't
I want to show you something kind of
interesting you see the enter and exit
have a sequencing to them the enter
always comes before the exit
what structure in Python is good for
enforcing sequencing that implies a core
metaphor of sequencing generators that's
kind of interesting right so maybe I
could take this in this statement and
stick them into a generator and maybe
the generator will take the cursor
assets as it's a argument and call this
one in this one and put a yield in
between right
enforcing sequencing and now my temp
table is now kind of fancy because what
it will do is it might say self dot G
equals an instance of this generator and
it might just do next of my generator
here and the next there and I might too
actually it is a little bit you got to
do it like this
of course the details are always a
little trickier but self talk to equals
self dot equals g TT of course and then
I actually have to do this these are all
details that simply do not matter ok
there we go and you can see this thing
works and all I've done is now this
thing just take some generator and it
puts it into the context manager
protocol and my generator here just
enforces the sequencing of creating the
table and tearing down well let me call
it something better like that and I
won't take this argument here I'll just
move that into here and I'll leave the
rest the same so the in it doesn't need
to take anything actually I'll take the
generator as my argument and I'll just
do this I'll call it GI for generator
instance
haven't done anything too magical now
this thing doesn't really reference it
it's ever a temp table I'll call this
thing up here temp table you can see it
enforces the sequencing and then I'll
just do this temp table equals context
manager tempt able to turn my generator
into something that fits into this
protocol right I just pass this in here
as its argument right I take the G I
capture the generator that was passed in
on enter I capture the cursor I advance
through the first argument here on exit
I advance the next argument and I'm done
and we got a call to make sure we
spelled these things right context
manager and then this oh oh my god
oh yeah there's a little trickier than
that but you'll see let's do this let's
stick it here little trick is always
there's always a couple more details
than you think but the details simply
don't matter what matters here what
fundamentally matters here always more
details than you think
but simply matters here is that what we
have here is this context manager thing
this generator that enforces its
sequencing and this line here that turns
our generator into a context manager
right now let me fix the bug that I had
in it originally and the bug is that
this needs to take a cursor here so I
want to show you something kind of
interesting
notice that this thing now has a call
method because it's it's called so we'll
bind the cursor and this call method
here it's what we're missing
and then this will work and will turn
itself okay so now this still works
now there's something really interesting
here I'm just going to move this code
down to the bottom do you see a pattern
here ever seen this pattern before
something equals call a function on
something and that original thing was a
function never seen that pattern before
what was it called decorator now our
code still works and it turns out my
sloppy crappy version of this that I
wrote we don't have to write it already
exists in context Lib here we go here we
have an example of a context manager a
generator and a decorator all together
in one place what you can see is each of
these features has a fundamental
metaphor behind it one of the
fundamental metaphors of generators is
enforcing sequences which is important
because we have to do that create the
table before we drop the table we fit
this into a context manager the
fundamental metaphor of context managers
is some teardown some set up in some
teardown that are paired together
we have that here as well we got a
create the temp table and if we create
it we got to make sure we destroy it the
last piece is a little bit of syntax
because we want to fit this structure
into the protocol a Python protocols
enter an exit and the way that we do
that is by calling a function that takes
a function or a generator and we have
our decorator syntax here do you see how
it didn't really matter in order to get
the code to actually work we asked to
futz around a little bit we had to move
lines around a little bit confusing
probably would have helped if we had
read through the documentation
beforehand probably would have helped if
maybe I warmed you up with a few more
jokes I don't know but it doesn't matter
if fundamentally doesn't matter when you
need to know the syntax
you'll go look it up what you might
never be able to find from the
documentation is what do these features
actually mean what are they actually for
who cares why do people care about them
and I think you see in the course of
last 90 minutes I showed you four core
parts of Python and I told you each of
them really fundamentally means let me
review metaclasses
they might mean many different things
and they might be used or misused in
many different places but fundamentally
they are your core or primary way to
make sure that if you have a class and
someone's going to derive from that
class that they do something you want
them to do or don't do something you
don't want them to do how do you do that
will they give you an area where you can
write arbitrary code to check their work
when they try to create their derived
class you have a little function that
you can hook into and you can say hey
you didn't implement this method I
wanted this method I marked as abstract
you didn't implement it this method that
you wrote I'm going to wrap it and
change its behavior slightly that's all
it is meda meda class is just in that
split-screen we're not on the right-hand
side anymore we're on the left-hand side
and we need to make sure people who use
our code on the right-hand side do
things in a certain way by forcing
ourselves onto them by means of this
hook all the meta classes
decorator merely syntax that makes it
convenient to use a core aspect of
Python namely that everything is an
object and everything is executed in
this linear fashion from top to bottom
including things like class statements
or function or generator definitions
because they're dynamic because they're
executed at runtime it means we can
create classes within functions create
functions within functions because their
executor means we can pass a function to
other function as an argument and the
decorator is merely a convenient syntax
to take this common pattern we see in
code make it easier to use the generator
is merely a way to very easily write
something that can be iterated over
where the key part is that on each
iteration what you do might be some
interesting computation as opposed to
just looking at the next element of a
list or the next element here you can
think fundamentally the easiest way to
bridge the two is that usually when you
think about it eration you think about
getting the next item from some sequence
what if that sequence is a row in a
database getting the next item is a
complex operation it's a network call
you have to go on to the network send
some information the database wait for
it to come back a generator is not how
those are typically implemented they're
typically implemented in terms of itter
and next that we saw before but you can
think there's a similarity between what
is done there and the core of what a
generator provides you but one side
effect of that or one consequence of
that is that generators also
fundamentally enforce the sequencing of
operations because when you yield from a
generator and you resume you can only
resume from the point where you last
left off finally a context manager as a
simple metaphor the simplest of all do
something to set up some state or some
context and make sure you clean up after
yourself afterwards if you open the
cupboard to get a cup make sure you
close it I never do that you come to my
house now that we're all friends if you
ever come to my house and I make you a
cup of tea please remind me to close the
cabinets because I seriously leave them
open all the time and please also remind
me to unplug the
because it's really a fire hazard ever
right next to my toaster
only there were context managers for
real life but they're not well I guess
they are that would be like a
housekeeper or something okay we're
getting too far off track fundamentally
a context manager is this pairing of
setup Ontario and the example I show you
here you can see all of them coming
together
the syntax for them of course you saw I
struggled a little bit to get it right I
struggle to remember all of the
arguments but it doesn't matter when you
see each of these independently you can
now begin to think well I want my
temporary table to be created before
it's dropped that sounds like sequencing
makes sense for that to be a generator I
if I'm going to write as a generator I
need to fit it into this protocol so I
need to have some class in the middle in
order to pass my generator into that
class I need some syntax that looks
really similar to the decorator syntax
and there we go
all the pieces fit together in one and
they fit together fairly seamlessly I'll
finish this example there's one last
thing I have to do to make this correct
and here this should stand as a complete
and correct example of how to create a
context manager using a decorator and a
generator
unfortunately I can't take a medical ass
in here as well or I could but it would
be gratuitous but you see there are some
metaphors behind the scenes should you
use these features all over the place no
of course not but now I hope that all of
you will understand that the details of
these features are important when you
need to use them and if you find that
you need to use them you'll have to look
at the details and say is this something
I can really use or not but I hope that
all of you especially those of you who
aren't commonly using these parts of
Python every day at least have a
starting point where you can say hey
this problem problem looks like
something I've seen before it's probably
a good use of a generator this problem
looks like something I've seen before
it's probably a good use of a meta class
and if you can understand that and
really fundamentally Intuit how Python
was designed and what these features are
really for the rest is just details what
you look up when you need to so those
are the four things I wanted to go over
I'll open for questions I don't know how
much time we have left since we're
schedule is a little bit different but
any questions we have Timmons that's
good in the front first what's your name
Stefan how you doing Stefan Stefan has
enough friends he doesn't need another
friend apparently oh I can be Stefan's
friend fantastic I just wrap their
function so when I got there derived
class yeah so the question is I brought
up an example where I use them at a
class not to check something but to
enforce some behavior the way it is in
the meta class I get the class you're
trying to construct right I can look at
it and make sure that it satisfies some
some requirements that I have but I can
also change it and so I can just take
any method you write and I can wrap it
using the same trick I did with the
decorator with my own method that does
the things I want so that was my
solution my solution was don't bother to
even have them call the special database
setup method we'll just take their
method today right and wrap them
ourselves and maybe behind the scenes
check the environment to see if the task
needs to be done or not there was
another question what happens in this
case the question is how can yield ever
throw an exception what happens in this
case is that when you when you you need
to be able to capture that exception if
it occurs because you might need to do
something with it
so what happens here is that generators
are a lot richer than just next they
have two other methods on them one of
them is called send the other ones
called throw send allows you to do
something a little bit more
sophisticated with generators and here
just as a brand-new metaphor that brand
new metaphors what's called a KO routine
what we saw with a generator versus a
function is that a function starts at
one point runs to the end with a
generator it starts at one point and
then you can kind of enter and re-enter
how do you stick information back in
every time we enter that's a
generalization from a subroutine that
runs take some arguments and run to
completion and a KO routine that takes
some arguments run to some point pauses
as you to pass in more arguments pauses
allows you to pass in more arguments
pauses by the way co-routines are very
important part of asynchronous
programming in Python the best
asynchronous libraries in python namely
curio and trio well ok the ones I like
the most maybe not the best but the ones
I like the most are built all around the
idea of coroutines well that's what send
is for what's throw for throw allows you
to throw an exception back up into a
generator what happens in this context
manager adapter is that when an
exception occurs inside the context the
context manager knows it because those
are what the arguments to exit were the
ones I can't remember the name of it's
like exception value exception type
things like that it'll take that and
we'll throw them back up into the yield
and the exception will be percolated on
line 10 here that's how a yield can
actually raise an exception it's not
being raised by the statement itself
it's being reinfected into the generator
from the outside to really understand
that you'll have to look at how
co-routines work because i think they're
very closely tied other questions and
you want to ever get anyone actually
going to use any of these features when
they get back to work who wasn't going
to use them before nobody so everyone's
going to use them before and they're
going to keep using them so I didn't
scare you away from the features that's
good you just may be more confident in
using I don't know but you can see they
mean something much deeper than just oh
you know here's some syntax this syntax
is the least interesting part of them
there's a question Oh is there not a
question okay well that's that's what I
wanted to show you this is something
which I wanted a shortcut for you what I
think takes a long time for people to
build in their mind people use these
features for years and years and years
and they keep throwing mental models
against the wall for how these things
work and what they mean until one sticks
what I wanted a shortcut for you is you
use these things enough and you start to
see patterns you try to figure out what
are these patterns imply you just steal
that and there you have a 90 minute pie
data talk anyone can do it so there you
go I hope you enjoyed that thank you
very much
you